[Musique]
il ya quelques jours j'étais au forum
innovation défense à paris un truc
complètement hallucinant dans lequel
l'armée nous présenter ses dernières
technologies dernier rénovation des
choses complètement folles
on passe par un homme qui volent dans le
ciel au dessus de la scène c'est un truc
c'est incroyable c'est au delà du réel
on crée ensuite un espèce de cape
d'invisibilité
c'est à dire en fait un un tank qui
devient invisible à quelque chose près
vous allez voir c'est ouf de la
reconstruction enfin pas mal de choses
c'est vraiment ce que je vous propose
on y retourne direction le forum
innovation défense et puis vous me direz
on commente à ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
devant un simulateur d'hélicoptère de
combat comme ça au moins pourrez vous
initier découvrir un petit peu ce qu'on
peut faire dans un hélicoptère de combat
de l'armée fait sur un robot qui
complètement hallucinant qui vous permet
d'imprimer directement vos propres
cellules qu on a prélevé sur votre corps
directement sur la place adresse
forcément aux grands brûlés on peut tout
reconstituer du cartilage des vaisseaux
à voir aussi du côté nerveux le tissu
enfin c'est vraiment une évolution qui
est complètement hallucinante ça c'est
vraiment une grande première alors pour
l'instant ce n'est pas complètement
terminée ils sont en train vraiment de
mettre cette technologie au point mais
c'est juste c'est juste hallucinant
[Musique]
comment molletonné et à l'épaule en fait
elle est polluée
[Musique]
montre le mec l'armée
là on est du côté de la marine avec un
drone aquatiques en drones qui sert pour
le déminage heures pour l'instant il
sert pas c'est quelque chose qui va se
mettre en place très rapidement va y
avoir des essais qui vont en effet très
rapidement qui devrait remplacer les
démineurs de la marine qui sont faits
pour l'instant par l'humain et l'idée
est justement c'est de supprimer
l'humain et de le faire directement avec
des drones aquatique erreur vous avez un
drones sous-marins fait 70 kg quand même
c'est une belle bête et vous avez aussi
un autre au nord-ouest une maquette qui
en réalité la taille d'un bateau qui est
complètement
téléguidé et vous avez à l'arrière une
petite partie qui est tracté qui va
faire ce job là et l'idée une fois vous
avez ça si vous voulez c'est le drone va
soit désamorcée la mine soit carrément à
la faire exploser
donc l'idée là dessus la technologie
c'est vraiment des drones qui vont aller
remplacer l'humain pour ne pas mettre en
péril des lignes là on parle des rations
alimentaires de l'armée
ça c'est super intéressant parce que au
final les militaires français mangent
très très bien ça il faut savoir c'est
d'ailleurs la première nation qui a dû
du vrai bon repas de la vraie bonne
bouffe là dessus vous avez si vous
regardez là bas on nous montre un petit
peu sous cloche
ce qu'on est en train de repasser juste
ouf c'est vraiment de la vraie vraie
bonne bouffe et en plus il ya un vrai
cahier des charges qui est super
intéressant là dessus c'est à dire
qu'elle la cuisine qui est fait sans
additif au niveau de la viande c'est des
vrais morceaux de viande c'est fait pour
avoir une longue conservation ces titres
pour avoir du goût c'est fait pour être
bon il ya aussi des rations halal est
par contre n'est pas gras sont
végétariennes tout simplement pour avoir
un vrai apport en protéines et notamment
par rapport à la consommation
calorifique pour toutes les calories
qu'on va pouvoir brouiller la journée
donc du coup il faut le savoir dans
l'armée française
on mange ouais mais par contre au moins
jeu super bien
encore à part d'une innovation qui
s'appelle le maître paquet dans le map
pack ça vient en gros on remplace gros
sacs utilisent les pompiers de paris le
met pas que c'est ça une grande valise
qui va s'ouvrir dans lequel vous avez
plein d'innovations donc là vous avez
tout votre kit d'urgence des veaux
pansements vous avez autre votre plateau
qui va bouger qui va venir tenir les
compresses tout simplement tout pour
pouvoir piquer vos perfusion vos
ampoules et en plus cela vous avez même
cette petite partie là qui va vous
servir à ouvrir les ampoules vous avez
votre récupérateur justement pour les
ampoules ici tout votre vos déchets donc
pour le dasri pour tout ce qui va être
piquant vous avez des plateaux latéraux
qui s'ouvre comme ça pour pouvoir bosser
enfin c'est un truc qui est vachement
bien fait vous avez de quoi poser les
perf en or vous avez un éclairage aussi
qui vous servira pour les soins et aussi
pour pouvoir voir votre plateau et votre
matos enfin le truc est franchement
vraiment bien fait c'est complètement
utilisés vous avez un autre côté là avec
toute une partie là c'est pour les
solutés dont classe avec surtout pour la
les perfusions pas de plateau sur le
côté il ya toute une partie enfin ça
c'est vraiment un truc pour l'urgence
qui est vraiment bien ça fait 8 kg là
bas je crois qu'on est quasiment à 20 kg
donc là pour le coup en terme de soins
d'urgence d'action d'urgence c'est
vraiment bien le but étant en cas
d'intervention d'éviter d'en [ __ ]
partout comment on a là autour d'un
patient un faux patient celui là il
vivra à jamais ses habitants tout 400
trouvait avec un bordel pas possible et
travaillent dans des conditions
d'hygiène qui sont franchement maîtrisé
[Musique]
eric est super intéressant c'est en
termes de camouflage c'est à dire que ça
espèce de groupe xl qu'on va poser sur
un tank tout simplement pour venir
camouflé en spa du petit pixel comme sur
un téléphone il faut imaginer à la
taille d'un temps que c'est un truc est
franchement énorme c'est des gros pixels
d'un côté du temps que vous avez une
caméra qui va filmer un petit peu le
décor tout simplement et la côte et les
pixels vont projeter la même teinte qui
fait qu en gros votre temps votre
véhicule en tout cas pas complètement ce
être camouflée et se fondre dans le
décor alors après on peut imaginer plein
de choses on met des couleurs qui vont
être différentes en fonction par exemple
dans le désert ce qu'on me disait par
exemple c'est que un désert au sel un
désert au mali d 09 tennis temps sera
forcément la même chose
donc c'est vraiment hyper la tête et ça
c'est vraiment super super intéressant
et en termes de technos a va vraiment
loin c'est super cool et on va aller
beaucoup plus loin en posant en pouvant
également moduler la température à
savoir que votre gros pixels à une
température pouvoir s'adapter pour ne
pas pouvoir être payés par des caméras
infrarouges donc c'est un camouflage
visuel un camouflage thermique et c'est
vraiment intéressant et ce qui est super
cool sur ce salon sur ce forum en tout
cas et c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment
intéressant de venir voir c'est parce
que des innovations qui sont dans le
domaine militaire arrive ensuite dans le
domaine civil
titi qui m'ont tout de suite il faudra
regarder c'est grâce à une techno
militaire internet internet quelque
chose qui date des années je présente
mes titres 70 64 des années 80 en tout
cas ça c'est une certitude qui vient à
la base de la recherche militaire
il ya plein de choses comme ça le
réfrigérateur enfin il vraiment cas d'
usage de recherche militaire qui ensuite
arrive dans six villes et c'est vraiment
cool là vous a typiquement sur un robot
qui revenir en gros porter vos bagages
hallyday justement dans l'armée c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de bagages
c'est très lourd c'est très compliqué là
la machine le fait pour vous elle passe
partout ça évite aux militaires d'être
complètement éclaté on peut transporter
beaucoup de choses c'est hyper sécurisé
et ça c'est pareil c'est une innovation
qui est hyper cool c'est pour ça que ce
forum est intéressant
dites moi ce que vous en pensez mais en
tout cas je commence à vraiment cool
pour moi quels sont les techno qui vous
ont plu intéressé a prié le truc est
vraiment intéressant c'est cette espèce
de de cerfs-volants de machines volantes
dans les yaks
[Musique]
ok
il a volé au dessus de la scène c'est un
truc assez ouf c'est une technologie par
contre là qui vient du civil et qui est
récupéré par l'armée
c'est vraiment complètement hallucinant
complètement bluffant voir ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui c'est un espèce de
overboard au volant une techno qui est
complètement folle c'est vraiment génial
c'est complètement incroyable
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire quel les techno qui vous a
le plus intéressé qu est-ce qui est ce
que vous pensez tout ça moi entrer ce
qui m'a vraiment bluffé c'est
l'imprimante pour venir imprimez vos
propres cellules faire de l'auto greffe
en gros avec une imprimante 3d au pays
imaginaire quand sera beaucoup de choses
là effectivement c'est dédiée aux grands
brûlés mais imaginez demain pour un
organe par exemple qui
un cancer sur une tumeur à pouvez faire
une ablation vous pouvez vous pouvez
imaginer reconstruire au paysage et de
la reconstruction de simples pour tous
les cancers du sein on peut imaginer
énormément de choses c'est donc vraiment
de très belles perspectives à la santé
et c'est vraiment vraiment tout
simplement génial voilà dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bons commentaires on
reste connectés ont laissé un peu comme
ça de temps en temps d'aller se mettre
un peu en immersion d'aller voir un peu
ce qui existe en dehors des techno grand
public notamment smartphones tablettes
ordinateurs cas c'est vraiment cool
voilà soyez sage très bientôt plus
embrasse choc